[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue sur le tournage du
court-métrage l'autre n'a pas besoin de
ça en fait 60 violence
qu'est ce qui se passe c'est pas ce
tournage et que je tâtonne fumée depuis
une demi heure
comment ça marche et on le suit
venez vous
6h et là on arrête
c'est un court métrage qui parle sur le
fait de se lancer et d'essayer d'avoir
le courage de se donner les moyens
d'aller au bout de ses rêves c'est une
thématique que j'aime beaucoup ce que un
moment j'ai dû faire aussi un choix très
personnel qui est de se dire je vais
faire un métier qui n'existe pas à
l'époque en tout cas j'ai arrêté mes
études j'ai arrêté de travailler pour
des employeurs tout ça donc c'est un
moment très bizarre de la vie mais non
mais du coup tu dois te lancer ce soir
non attends je suis pas prêt moi je peux
commencer ce soir c'est pas possible
j'ai pas de tête j'ai rien je vais de
coacher ce soir tu montes sur scène on
est trop court en fait au fond tous les
deux sont drôles tous les deux ont
toujours eu ce truc là c'est juste qu'à
un moment il ya eu un événement et je
pense qu'en fait dans la vie des gens
ils savent de quoi je parle mais il ya
eu des petits trucs où tu les tiens je
vais essayer ça vous tester ça et ça
joue à rien d symboliser sa part une
rencontre avec jamel debbouze et et
c'est du moins ce qui poserait problème
19e le bol et là je devais avoir 7
écoles frérot galles mardi a dit sutter
et je me suis dit ils imaginent
quelqu'un il dit partir je lui donne un
contact l'autre cuisinant je vais m'en
fous je laisse passer ces petits moments
charnières donc du coup imaginons que
ces deux personnes divise à ce moment là
puis se retrouve un peu plus tard en
fait c'est la rue nos vies sont
différentes c'est pas mon mois du futur
ou je sais pas quoi
j étais à l'anniversaire de steam j'ai
croisé djamel sauf que on n'a pas
discuté au final henin qui épanouit mais
qui allait un peu trop loin dans son
arrogance et l'autre qui déprime un
petit peu dans son travail
c'est ça c'est ça la grosse différence
mais c'est quand même la même personne
les manques l'habite donc je vais d'être
là faire s'il te plaît lis moi une fois
les la's en commun lie la coutume ans
c'est important pour moi d'avoir une
histoire aussi pour jean
il faut quelque chose qu'il ait perdu
faut quelque chose que quand il arrivait
dans ses rêves et ses îles et fait aussi
des mauvais choix
leïla c
et une âme d'artiste qui est vrai est
consciente d'être en vie et qui pousse
copains j h à aller de l'avant et à
faire ce qui lui fait peur elle sent que
son mec n'est pas tout à fait lui-même
pas trop ce qui se passe mon personnage
le bois pas comme quelque chose qui va
mal entre nous mais plus
ce souci de
de ce que j'ai un chat dans la tête et
donc l art présente ça c'est à dire
c'est ce qu'il a perdu lui en chemin une
phrase que j'ai dit qu'il est juste sans
fin c'est bien de faire des gens mais
s'il fait pas rire la bonne personne à
quoi ça sert que ça c'est parfois tu te
lances dans ton art ces deux thématiques
de ou du film whip l'achat d'or s'est
battue est lancé à fond mais est-ce que
ce que ça te rend heureux j'en parle
aussi dans mon court métrage fait un
voeu c'est quelqu'un qui perd un petit
peu tous ses rêves au fur et à mesure
mais on a des nouveaux qui vont
apparaître et qui sont représentés par
bata compagne ton compagnon ta famille
tes amis
donc voilà il faut pas se perdre en
route non plus noble que je connaissais
assez bien milieu je tenais beaucoup de
jus plein d'amis qui font du stand-up
ray un côté encore plus se lancer tout
seul et face à un public un peu tu es un
peu à nous d'ailleurs en parlant de
stand-up
c'est quoi les conseils pour monter sur
scène pour s'améliorer
vous jouez souvent pour jouer souvent il
faut trouver des endroits où jouer donc
ça déjà c'est pas facile parce qu'il
n'ya pas tant de soirée que ça et puis
en 3 même si ça commence à bien aller
ben il faut beaucoup s'investir
il n'y a pas de recette miracle qui a
pas de truc qui va dire ça c'est drôle
où ça c'est pas drôle y est que le
public il va te le dire du coup bah ça
tu peux la prendre quand montant sur
scène puis tu progresses il ya une envie
farouche une énergie l'envi une patate
quelque chose dont tu es convaincu quoi
s'étaient convaincus
[Musique]
on a pas mal de plans ou il y est j h en
même temps ce qu'on a fait c'est que
déjà on a engagé une doublure la
doublure qui ressemblait le plus à
cyprien possible sur beaucoup de plans
ou va me voir sur des amorces de dos
pierre mairat sera derrière on verra que
mes mains
mes pieds un bout d'oreille à plein
d'effets spéciaux différents
ja on tourne deux fois la même séquence
et okubo milieu petit split screen on
voyait un personnage et sur fond bleu on
le détourne incruste alors pour les
interactions physiques c'est un peu plus
compliqué à mettre en place notre savant
la scène devant le comedy club pour
cette salle est en fait on a cette fois
une astuce avec une
avec la doublure de cyprien qui viennent
en fait faire une accroche directement
sur son visage da pour le combat à venir
effacer son bras je veux garder son
corps et me remettre les uns sur les
autres
hélas le summum carrément on va incrusté
un plan dans un autre plan en mouvement
avec un petit mapping 3d des familles
est une d'ici je dis des conneries je
suis un peu dans l'effet spécial voilà
le plus compliqué c'est déjà que le cac
ne bouge pas que je puisse me changer
rapidement et surtout que je puisse
changer de personnage même si
techniquement c'est la même personne
qu'ils ont un peu le même état d'esprit
mais pendant plusieurs mois ils ont
beaucoup évolué nains qui s'est un peu
renfermé sur lui-même et l'autre dit est
monté sur scène donc les beaucoup mis
dans ses pompes donc que parfois je dois
être un peu stressée juste après détente
c'est métier de comédien n'est ce pas
donc il faut absolument apprendre le
texte par coeur sera mieux c'est pour
donner une réplique et tout sera là
d'oubli
hop
pour en [ __ ]
qu'est-ce qui se passe
c'est pas ce tournage ouah
[Musique]
on est le quatrième jour de tournage on
est à créteil là on met
on peut pas tourner en fait parce qu'il
ya
les manifestants qui garde notre camion
il ya tout le matériel tout la caméra
les lumières et tout ça et les parkings
là ont été bloqués avec des banderoles
on peut plus de réforme des retraites
donc on est comme des cons ne pas avoir
de matériel donc on essaie de trouver
des solutions pour mais malheureusement
ça va tout décalés de plusieurs heures
ça va se ressentir sur voilà sur
l'énergie
maintenant
je laisse plus les jours son tournage et
j'assiste cyprien parce que quand il est
comédien il peut pas regarder le combo
il peut pas regarder tout ce qui se
passe à l'image il peut pas se diriger
lui-même timoteo celle qui m'a dirigé
déjà dans le court métrage de la science
de l'amour
on a été un peu taillé pour ça je vais
dix mecs je tourne ça mais je fais plus
je le réalise mes jeux que plusieurs
personnages à l'intérieur il faut
quelqu'un qui soit derrière le moniteur
et qui puisse me dire vas-y fêter cette
réplique latter ce jeu là
c'est moins son agent on peut peut être
pas travailler ensemble à la pelle
edberg
[Musique]
c'était super u des décors qui sont up
comedy club le paname qui sont des lieux
quand même assez emblématique dans pour
le stand up
t'as vu comment on fait des bijouteries
ici c'est le paname en fait on a fait
trois décors ici le paname lag la salle
de la petite salle de théâtre
le café la bijouterie et faisant
commenge ici aussi
donc voila merci pas là et on est de
l'extérieur n'est de l'appartement aussi
est très arty on comprend bien l'univers
du personnage il est là pour les
peintures de leïla c'est l'artiste mady
qui nous a prêté ses toiles et son
matériel des pinceaux des esquisses des
chiffons son univers graphique est
parfait pour le personnage c'est
élégance et féminins puis on a sonné
j'ai eu la chance d'avoir pas mal de
figurants sont venus c'est cool je
trouve pour inclure un petit peu sa
communauté des gens qui t'apprécie dans
tes propres projets tu vois c'est pas
tout on peut faire ça tu vas donc j'ai
sauté sur l'occasion
[Applaudissements]
on n'est pas sur youtube là c'est pas
pour internet ce qui fait la fédé
cinoche suis mon doigt un bonne toi
abonne toi sinon j'en chie watts et je
brûle nos rages rideau
[Musique]